was ist das für ein scheiß hallo mein
name ist luca und ich hab eigentlich
absolut keine ahnung von minecraft aber
trotzdem stelle ich euch jede woche
commands vor der erste command wurde mir
zugesendet von lucky genie o m c der
commander auch jetzt richtig wenig
aufrufe allerdings ist er umso cooler
und zwar gehe ich erstmal ein / pippi
command unterstrichen block um einen
komplott zu erhalten dazu hole ich mir
noch einen elfer um das ganze ding zu
aktivieren
dann legt sich das hier vorne hin gebe
den kommunen der von lakic mcs drücke
den schalter und ihr seht schon wenn
dieses ding dort oben den reds zum blog
er erreicht hat sehen wir schon eine
maschine baut sich auf und hey bord die
maschine auf ob ich mir etwa aufgebaut
wir haben und im inventar die items pon
berner test & destroy bernard es wenn
ich jetzt einfach mal dieses weiter mir
nehmen und dort hinsetzen bekomme ich
eine kiste wenn ich diese seite
irgendwie hin setzte geht die kiste
definitiv nicht kaputt zweite seite
brauchen wir auch gar nicht das gibt uns
irgendwie nur unnötig die ganze zeit
leder und beef aber das ist vollkommen
egal wir konzentrieren uns erstmal diese
kiste und zwar ist das alles was dieser
command hinzufügt und zwar diese kiste
mit verschiedenen buchstaben das coole
ist jetzt ihr braucht natürlich ihr
könnt banner machen indem wir die
einfach quasi macht aber das dauert sehr
lange
deswegen gibt es seit diesem command wo
ihr euch einfach beispielsweise jetzt
lcd und nehmen könnte und dann kann ich
jetzt einfach mal lu c&a hier hinsetzen
dann sehen wir schon luca mit einem
command way das ist alles was dieser
erste command hinzufügt und zwar ist das
eine sehr sehr coole sache bzw auch eine
sehr simple sache aber eine sehr coole
sache ist zwar auch er sehr sehr simpel
aber auch sehr cool obwohl die sache
sehr sehr sitzt roman nummer zwei ist
von sport und zwar wirklich den command
block wieder hin gebe dort den command
ein und zwar ist es ein cookie clicker
command cookie clicker kennen vielleicht
einige von euch dass es von spiel 6
anklicken muss desto mehr kekse du hast
desto geiler kannst du dich fühlen und
so weiter und so fort und wir sehen
schon
jeden moment wir diese maschine kreiert
denn der red sox genau jetzt erreicht
wir haben hier die maschine und wir
sehen hier vorne schon drei schilder und
zwar einmal cookie ticker bei sport.de
und right click to remove das heißt wenn
ich rhyme click to play clique bin ich
hier oben mitten in der luft auf sondern
kleinen insel und wir sehen schon da
kostet beispielsweise 15 zu wort und
wenn ihr mal rechts in der tabelle guckt
wenn ich jetzt die ganze zeit
rechtsklick hier darauf mache bekomme
ich halt umso mehr cookies ich bin jetzt
beispielsweise gerade bei 90 cookies
jetzt bin ich schon bei den 100 jetzt
bin ich bei den 110 und jetzt bin ich
auch schon mal den 120 und wenn jetzt
kommt die 1 funktion und zwar kann ich
mir beispielsweise den cursor für 15
kaufen da sehen wir schon der cursor
generate 0,1 cookies das heißt wenn ihr
das jetzt mal seht oben links oben
rechts bei meinen cookies jetzt 10 109
habe ich jetzt beispiel zwei bis 110
also es geht quasi von alleine hoch ohne
dass ich drücke da ich allerdings noch
101 cookies hat kann ich mir auch so
eine grand marnier kaufen das heißt kost
100 ich klick darauf und ihr seht jetzt
oben rechts das geht schon deutlich
schneller auf das heißt wir sind jetzt
bei 12 jetzt sind wir beispielsweise
schon bei 17 18
jetzt sind wir schon war
23 also es geht quasi viel viel
schneller jetzt hoch und desto mehr kick
sich nachher habe desto mehr kekse half
ich nachher das ist quasi cookie clicker
und man kann das paar sie dann
ich könnte jetzt wieder die ganze
draufklicken und dementsprechend immer
mehr klicks bekommen und dann für 100
könnte ich mir noch eine weitere grammer
kaufen ist können wir mal eben machen
das heißt ich bin genau jetzt bei 100
kaufen beispielsweise noch nicht rentner
und jetzt sie mir schon oben recht
bekomme ich quasi immer sehr viele
cookies ohne dass ich wirklich richtig
drauf klicken muss ich bin jetzt
beispielsweise schon bei der 17
jetzt beispielsweise schon wieder bei
der 27 und so weiter und so fort ich
kann dann auch hier einfach wieder auf
exit klicken dann bin ich wieder unten
und auch wenn ich hier unten bin geht da
oben bei dem kieker games sieht man
vielleicht da ganz so ein bisschen sieht
man eigentlich gar nicht dass da oben
läuft allerdings weiter also es ist
scheißegal ob ich hier unten bin ob ich
im netter bin weiß ich gar nicht ob es
dann weiter läuft das könntet ihr
eventuell mal testen es läuft auf jeden
fall weiter und das ist kummer 2 von
sport und jetzt kommt der beste roman
den ich je vorgestellt habe
viele denken jetzt bestimmt 1000 mops
oder millionen waffen aber nein es ist
etwas besseres und zwar gebe ich den
command eindrücke auf den schalter und
wir sehen schon eine maschine wird
direkt kreiert und es der command ist
installiert und zwar ist es der
toiletten und biologischer kreislauf bei
der anonyme 13 und an der stelle muss
ich echt mal sagen freunde bitte
klickten die beschreibung und schaut
euch sein vorstellungsvideo an
ich hab mich so schlapp gelacht es ist
so schlecht gemacht ist ein grüner rand
amsan also ein grüner streifen am rand
der hat dann immer so richtig schlecht
sachen da eingefügt und dann einfach so
eine richtige art style mucke und so
dumm erklärt und auch heute wie wir
dieses video ich hab mich so kaputt
gelacht schaut euch das einfach an
wirklich wenn ihr schlechten tag habt
habt schaut euch einfach an wie er da
seine seinen command vorstellt und zwar
sehen wir jetzt schon jetzt geht es in
etwa los ich hab mich schon speed
bekommen und wir sehen rechts was glaube
ich für scheiße stehen soll oder so das
geht jetzt immer höher und er im video
hat er zur sachen eingefügt oh nein
ihr müsst ihr machen heißen desto
nötiger ihr scheiß müsste desto
schneller werde tier und wenn man jetzt
irgendwie rein theoretisch schon ich
habe jetzt beispielsweise speech und
wünschen richtig schnell
und irgendwann ist es jetzt zu spät und
ich hab es nicht passen zur toilette
geschafft und dann scheiße ich mich ein
ich weiß nicht genau da ist es gerade
passiert so sieht's aus ich habe mich
jetzt kein geschissen und ich habe jetzt
eine hose an die steht scheiße ha ha du
hast dich ein geschissen
so ein scheiß und ich habe jetzt hier
diesen betrunkenheit effekt und haltlos
und speed für immer glaube ich sogar
oder also die zahlen gehen ja nicht
besser als vor immer noch den effekt ich
glaube ich habe jetzt mein leben lang
bevor euch irgendwie schlecht wird muss
ich wirklich sagen
der kanal ist somit der behinderte glaub
ich dieses schiff vorgestellt hab' ich
würde sagen bevor wir jetzt einen
drehwurm bekommen wir endlich mal das
video lieber schnell und zwar wenn es
euch gefallen würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen
schaut euch dieses behinderte video das
ist auch so scheiße also wirklich
scheiße da würde ich sagen wir uns in
der nächsten video wieder deuce